le Fab entre West lo et Magnus Carlsen
bah les deux meilleurs joueurs de ce
tournoi qui se font face à nouveau après
c'est déjà croisé bien sûr dans le dans
le tableau principal et qui vont
s'affronter quatre fois aujourd'hui
peut-être 5 quatre fois demain peut-être
5 peut-être h et donc peut-être qu's
vont s'affronter une quinzaine de fois
là sur sur le tournoi et donc je pense
on pourrait bien savoir qui est le le
grand champion alors après j'ai envie de
te dire non va me faire l'avocat du
diable puisque westo avait gagné le
match entre les deux hommes en Pol
et et il n'a pas cet avantage
là non il joue B3 alors il suit les
conseils de de carwana je sais pas s'il
va suivre mes conseils aussi parce qu'il
m'a liké il a mis un petit like sur mon
conseil d play quick and
well Fabiano il lui a dit look one be
for white and
black je sais pas suiv tous nos
conseils
mais c'est F Magus pas risé paren fait
écrit sur Twitter faire
ça il a pas il a rien cont ouioui je
faire ça très heureux de
Fabiano qu' s'en fout complètement
W à nouveau gêné par la
lumière j'ai de magn des fois je joue
comme ça moi
no double F avec les blanc tu faire G4
là c'est pas
bon dommage trou partout il y en a qui
font c'est un peu con STR
TR moin bien quoi bon c'est pas absurde
mais
donc
faire très heureux quoi
c'est beau c'est challenge secondaire un
si important de d'arriver à concilier
les deux mais c'est vrai que ça existait
pas trop non c'est c'est full troll à
l'époque général tu voulais pas dévoiler
ton ouverture quand même des trahisons
comme ça des histoires et
là là c'est bien
ouais je crois qu'il s'en fiche un petit
peu aussi il clique surtout
est-ce que tu peux faire E4
là pourquoi pas je sais
pas
[Musique]
4 4 D6 à priori
ouais oui non mais tu aurais pu vouloir
faire F4 aprèsfin je fer G3 avec les
Blancs
je mais tu vas pas transposer dans un
truc qui est pas mal bah tu transposes
dans peu te faire de la symétrie à fond
ça va pour tout le monde tu as pas un
truc tuas C en C3 tu fais des4 en
premier tu es genre un peu mieux ouais
bon ça va pour les
Noirs faire G3 fou G2 après quand
même là je recr avec les noirs et
j'attends de voir le setup des blancs
sur C3 tu peux m me faire probaement D5
si tu fais une sorte de greenf vas-y
explique-nous pourquoi B3 fou B2 c'est
bien
et s fait G3 bah tu peux faire fou B7
c'est une V qui existe ça c'est
là mais mais c'est jouable pour les
blancs il y a pas
de pas de problème là-dessus
quoi ce
B3 j au bon moment par Wesley il a suivi
les conseils de
Twitter je pense que Twitter va être
très heureux
extraordinaire on se
délecte je regarde si soir écrit des
trucsil parle un peu de son chat sur
Twitter h d'ailleurs qui s'en occupe en
ce
moment et cont il dit qu'il joue pour
pour pour une boîte de thon pour les
chats TR
heureux en tout cas Magnus qui a roquet
on voir donc westle comment il compte
jouer si tu veux faire du G3 ça serait
logique mais tu peux peut-être jouer
avec E3 aussi ce soit peu ambitieux à
mon à mon avis j'ai trois ok pour moi
c'est le plus logique
il é très mécontent du film de Ridley
Scott Napoléon je crois ah ouais mais
c'est pas le seul qui est pas content je
suis pas sûr soit fidèle à la réalité
après bon j'aime bien l'acteur joaim
Phenix et j'ai pas vu le film donc j'ai
pas d'avis personnel dessus
quoi il est très mécontent mais
normalement il les Scotte belle pour
réalisateur
quoi il content de quoi lui bah il te
dit que c'est nul en
faitpp napoon movieig F
of general of all
time inur my naponice
epic history TV far better
J il pens pas très accurate hiss énervé
et après il te montre une photo sur son
autre poste il a 3h de son chat qui est
sur son iPad son
ordi
son
voy thanks to all the well wishes and
the prayers take it easy on me today
Magnus show some love make the mat fun
interesting peace très heureux quoi très
heureux de tout mais ditune fois qu'il
serait qualifié au candidat il arrêterit
de tweeter quoi si il est qualifié au
candidatin moi je bientôt tweet à an je
est-ce que tu as pas peur est beaucoup
plus intéressant que toi sur Twitter il
met des chats quoi enfin non mais il en
a deux maintenant il a de chats ouais ok
il est beaucoup plus intéressant quoi
tweet si souite un Joyeux Noël
enfin il est extraordinaire en fait
Wesley déj envoy des photos de son chat
partout et mais ils sont hyper grands en
fait c'est un peu des des des tigres des
neige quoi ces
chats on est pour sa non je pense il
sympa comme d'ab il a bien fait 3 comme
prévu avec le fion quietto et du coup à
Magnus de jouer je vooueris E6 ici moi
sa place un coup tout terrain gardant
toutes les options
il est vraiment vraiment marrant ce
Wesley joueur
sympathique dans vrai style de jeu pas
toujours flamboyant mais
bon
je crois aussi que c'est le les échecs
ça le saoule un peu donc il a pas
forcément toujours envie
de de combattre mais là il nous fait une
belle partie encore aujourd'hui beau
début de tournoi beau début de
finale
Magnus finir son développement avec ce
cavali6 qui a pas trop de rebond en tout
cas si les blanc jouer avec D5 dans la
ce C5 qu peut-être venir aussi en B4 un
jour à voir et pu les j D5 C5 le
cavalier aura son rôle à jouer donc
développement souple faire23 cavalier E5
probablement
[Musique]
ouis
on peut après prob coup comme
cavalier4 un moment un autre je suis pas
s bon
timing le en fait
G5 pr F2
aussi
G2 pour récupér G5
ensuite rap bien parce que cavalierok tu
prends quand même un vrai risque qui un
problème puis je au cas où au cas où CAV
4 ça va ça va ENF mais c'est pas non
plus grave hein parce que je peutêtre
cavalier E5 aussi sur C4 en tout il a
fait E3 coup de placement qui libère
aussi la case2 pour la dame qu'on AA
bien jouer un coup pareil pourah voilà
libérer la tour F1 ou quoi c'est V que
la dame en C2 D3 elle peut être touché
par K B4 en D2 a pu toucher par cavalier
4 donc en E2 ça semble être sa meilleure
case pour pour se développer
tranquillement et puis se garde tous les
choix avec son cavalier B1 qui peut
encore en C3 voire même en A3
je CIS cavalier5 par contre sans trop
réfléchir pour créer le vis-avis le long
de la longue
diagonale il a
pris pas bête non plus
hein y a pas d' pr à cause de cavalier
H4 probablement encore que mais C4 qui a
C3 ça doit
aller fa prendre des 5 et C3 vient avec
tempo et cavalier prend peut-être tu
fait cavalier 5 à ce moment-là
pe faire E4 aussi tu peux aussi faire E4
ouais peut-être hein on va voir il
pourrait retourner en
F6 FD2 il pris du pion du
coupélimination du reste et peut-être
quand même cavalier E5 euh on peut avir
une structure de pion pendant à
venir est-ce qu'on jouerait pas cavalier
C3 c'est ce que j'allais dire parce
Queau moins on se prépare vraiment au
pion
pendant sur C5 peut même commencer par
fois 3 ou peut-être prendre puis va
aller à 4
vite alors après les n bon est-ce que
ils veulent faire C5 direct çaurait du
sens mais il peuvent aussi mettre le
pion C6 ramener le C en C7 faire des
choses pour regarder plus de soupless
mais à priori ils veulent quand même
jouer avec C5 c'est c'est leur plan
est-ce que je peux pas faire cavalier B5
ici sur C6 tu vux faire FO 3 B4
ouis je sais pas dame D de peut-être à 5
bon je sais
pas bon il a fait tour C1 qui est un
coup logique he qui place col ouvert il
se prémunit de C5 pour le enfin il se
prémunit il interdit pas C5 évidemment
mais il place les pièces
pourouer
ouais partie très intéressante pour le
moins combat stratégique
Fab c'est un peu le tire Magnus tout ça
quand même ouais mais attention au chat
de West de West qui joue quand même pour
une boîte de
thon non c'est vra qu' il a vraiment
écrit jou pour la boîte de thon
donc dans un jeu assez important pour
pour les chats quoi
les chats on manger des des croquettes
pour avoir le droit à manger du
thon un M qualité
ouais
ouais enfin met de
qualité c'est ça qui
réfléchit parce que rien n décidé faut
pas voilà fautouer des coups qui peuvent
être utiles un peu sur tous les cas de
figure euh il a joue tour1 et donc le C5
a été joué maintenant donc soit on prend
et on crée les fameux pions pendant soit
on peut peut-être maintenir la tension
euh amener le cant E2 F4 peut être une
idée des fois dans ce genre de situation
ça réouvre la vue au fou B2 ça fa une
pression sur sur D5 le cabant F4 est
bien
stable donc c'est une option après faire
faire d prend C5 c'est bien aussi he
lesor vont reprendre de B pas du
cavalier qui certes serait bien plant C5
mais quand même ça donne la la belle
case D4 et je suis pas sûr qu'il a assez
d'activité pour les noirs pour se donner
un pion isolé comme ça donc j'imagine
sur D PRC B
PRC et l'autre tour viendra en tour ac8
et après à regarder toutes les percé
possibles de part et d'autre position
stratégiquement comme tu disais
intéressante et
vivante
ça réfléchi côté
Westley tu dois être mieux avec les
Blancs quand même les pion pendant c'est
pas bien réputé
ouais je sais pas exactement pourquoi
mais c'est pas si mal
[Musique]
hein c'est pas si mal ah tuas un petit
tweet avec ou le match
tantattendu sur de jours sur de jours
bien sû ce n'est que la première manche
évidemment ser un peu dommage de finir
dès aujourd'hui et ça n sera l'occasion
de nous délecter demain également mais
évidemment le vainqueur de la manche du
jour prendra une option
mais ne prévaut de rien on a bien
vu emporter le premier set contre
Westley et pourtant s'écroulé finalement
cavalier E4 VO tout est possible mais
euh je pense que ce serait mieux pour le
spectacle et et pour pour pour pour ce
match que westler remporte le le premier
set Magnus avec un set d'avance
onimagine pas s'écrouler ensuite les
deux derniers coups de de westle ont pas
été terriblees he qui B5 dame 2 il donne
cavalier 4 qui est B4 il va donner des
fou à6 la cavalerie arrive la cavalerie
arrive Fab
qu'il aurait dû accepter plus rapidement
de jouer ses pions pendant quand même il
aurait pu prendre et vite faire cavalier
à 4 fois 3 semblait intéressant quand
même il ne l'a pas
fait c'est
malheureux rien n'est grave mais
attention de pas
se laisser contrer
ouis après il du penser que K B5 é
intéressantvite tour C8 donc ça
maintient la tour dans le coin là-bas
mais c'est peut-être que K B4
intéressant al pare il fautéflchir à
qu'il y a pas A3 ou quoi mais se
redirigerait vers vers C6 et quea des A6
ou F6 au noir et C6 serait pas trop mal
placé puisque le 4 prend soin de bien
défendre C5 on n pas une grande pression
sur le pondé donc donc pourquoi
pas on va
voir on va voir
Fab plus 9 minutes 10 pour
Magnus a quand même une belle avance he
qui a joue assez vite cette
ouverture a 515 de son
côté qui veut peut-être échanger en C5
pour échanger les fout de case
noir
peut-être
moment important en tout cas parce que
là ça y les deux armées se confrontte et
c'est l des
choix la structure dans le placement des
pièces on un jeu de manœuvre au
début on est dans le jeu
concret il y a beaucoup d'échanges
possibles hein
h mais ouais mais k B4 je suis pas
ok c'est une de l'ordi mais je dis je
fais A3 il repart en C6 je fais dprend
C5 à ce moment-là il reprend ou il fa
prend B2 je sais pas j'échange les fou
de case noir et après peut-être que ce
pion A3 en plus il peut être utile parce
que il peut m'aider à faire B4 à péter
le pion C5 et c'est une manière de
lutter contre ces pions pendant donc ça
do pas être un coup facile à jouer
humainement surtout que sur A3 je crois
que l'ordi il veut jouer kivalé
A2 les sans murer là-bas et sur tour un
faire A6
ouais non c'est pas je veux dire si on a
déjà analé l'ordi vu ses trucs ça peut
venir au cerveau mais ouais mais bon là
il on pas là c'est pas une position
qu'ils ont analysé non non mais si c'est
un thème que tu as déjà vu je ne sais où
tu vois euh par exemple souviens d'une
partie aux Olympiades de Sébastien
Feller qui avait fait un kb4 cavalier à
de comme ça ouais mais c'est vraiment
dur hein bah d'ailleurs oui c'était des
Olympiades
où il y a quelques soucis de mais du
coup à part des parties comme ça j'ai
jamais trop vu de je plus a en C2 mais
bon
cétait qui semble partir à l'abattoir
mais qui en fait est pas
prenable il y va à 3 s'il joue qu' à de
bravo bah il a bravo
Magnus faire t a
priori assz direct quand même c'est
assez direct mais gen faut y penser
quoi mais je ça doit aller pour westle
hein tu fais tour à un tu attaques ce
cavalier il doit absolument faire A6
parce que sinon le cavalier a 2 est
perdu fa DC ouais déponer tu récupères
le cavalier 2 tu perd ton k B5 et euh ça
s change un peu on verra bien joué en
tout cas de la part de Magnus là ça joue
mieux là la final h
h bon DC c'est logique quand
même bah ouais ouais c'est logique parce
qu'on ouvre cette grande diagonale et la
dame joue long de la de la seconde
rangée et il pourrait pourrait capturer
des choses c'est quand même logique quoi
de prendre en premier car de toute façon
pour le moment il
est
enfermé mais quelle vistade Magnus quand
même he ouais
c'était trouvable mais non non c'était
trouvable mais il
faut bah faut avoir l'idée quoi je veux
dire juste c'est pas simple d'avoir
l'idée
impossible n'est pas
Magnus peut être pas si
mal fait des
Français
ce qu'il va faire il fait quoi à par
exemple
G77 pr C5 et peuttre d B2 ou B4 d'abord
c'est ce moment pour casser cette
structure B4 on va dire
C4
et
cavalier aès passé je veux dire on a des
arguments de part et d'autre quoi
bon pion à TR arrière et
peut-être en tout cas il a pris ce pion
C5 on s'attend à prend B ou pr B2 B2
ouais comme ça dame prend prends à 2
tu ah mais peut-être s fut prendre prend
B2 a prend B5 on a C6
intermédiaire histo de pas redonner la
belle structure à
l'adversaire ça qu'
réfléchit il faut pr pr prend
C5 c'est peut-être
contre
4 là direct
[Musique]
directali c'est marrant ch
faisable et d'ailleurs peut-être même
sur F2 d
B2 une fois pour pas B5
je trouve qu'il a quand même du bol de
pas être moins bien Magnus là tuas
l'imession que tu aurais pas mal de cas
où il y a un C6 qui se cale ou un
cavalier D4 qui se cale et qui te
mais il a bien réfléchi avant de le
faire donc ou il a rien
vu je pense qu'il a pas vu plus loin que
ça ah bon quand tu as joué machin je
pense
pas prend G7 3 prend on pensa mais il a
pas C6 mais non il fait C3 et dame B2
prend C6 cavalier D4 encore cétait pas
fini encore la ligne donc peut-êre B4
voilà bah écoute c'est la première dont
on parlait C4 sûrement il nont pas du
tout envie de faire pion prend parce
qu'il y a dame B2 échec et on récupère
le pion B4 aprèsc une structure toute
pourrie pour les noirs et les cases
faibles partout sur case noir donc il
faut fermer le jeu pas se laisser va
venir en D4 c'est complexe donc chacun s
faiblesse il y aura un magnifique C D4
mais il y a un pion faible à 3 les noirs
sont aussi assez actifs le fou B7 pas
terrible mais il peut revenenir en C8 un
jour bah c'est le genre de partie qu'on
attendait tout au long du
tournoi une partie d'échec quoi non mais
une belle bon niveau non mais je veux
dire
oui on a eu trop peu des des parties de
cette
akavi c'est pas pour rien qu'ils ont
fini prier et deuxè hein h ils joue
mieux que il j vraiment honnêtement
mieux que les
autres
je suis en train de réfléchir mais ouais
c'est 4 dam B2 qui des4 moi je préfère
les
blancs je préfère nêement les
blancs si Magnus éta content de sa
position il aurait joué plus vite
là il est sous les 3 minutes maintenant
enfin sous les 315 et sous W
lesau qui démarre très fort ce match
ouais non mais c'est enfin je trouve ça
pas clair moi la position mais c'est pas
de goû aussi he mais Mo j'ai
l'impression d'avoir des moi je suis
content quand j'ai des idées claires en
fait là le D4 qui tape sur le pion B5 ça
me fait tellement plaisir non mais toute
façon c'est ce qu'on fait on fait d B2
D4 de prochains qu'on les a mais ilons
que F D6 euh r tour d un cavalier2 qui
C3 du
coup deux pions avec mon cavalier et
après ouais faut voir si les Noirs
arrivve à s'activer ici ou là avec des
H5 ou quoi du jeu à droit quoi H5 H4 et
cetera parce le jeu va être un peu coupé
en deux mais les Noirs vont devoir se
diriger vers cette vers
croit on verra
Fabien en tout cas c'est sûr que Magnus
il a la même sensation que
moi que sinon tu te il pris j'aurais pas
fait c'estre bien jou pere peutêtre
qu' bien réfléchi pour sécher qui mettre
une tour en A4 ou en C4 ou un truc comme
çaprs je suis pas d'accord avec l'ORD
parce que tuis l'ordi dame prend roi
prend pion prend tour prend tour prend
et tour C8 moi j'aurais eu peur de fou
F1 je tiens la case C4S le cavalier
en j'aime pas sa ligne alors j'aime pas
du
tout F de qui fait que ça tient je tour
C2 je veux dire mais bon il y a il fout
D3 je crois
ouais tour B2 tour B1 T b de tourb en
fin de
ligne non mais il doit faire tenir hein
c'est sûr
mais mais là il a peut-être que tuchange
en B1 il fait c C3 il veut qu' A2 C D
de non mais sûr qu'il la tient bon d
prend mais dans tout cas de ouais c'est
mais c'est bien ce que j'allais dire
c'est même pas la seule question parce
qu'en fait il y aussi d'AM pr mais qui
j'aurais probement fait ok c'est ça
l'idée
euh joli coup bon ben c'est e forcéok
prend les P
F2 on sattend prend peut-être qu' prend
G3 mais on peut F prend peut-être donc
non prend prend F prend tour F1 d' prend
des4 prise prise prise et F3 qui tombe
il l'a pas vu hein regarde ils su
ouais mais la position était vraiment
dure enfin il était vraiment pas
content force
B3 allez
Wesley allez le chat Ilir les chats qui
regardent à fond il se lèent les B il VO
leur boîte de thon peut-être se
matérialisé dans leur rêv les plus fous
c'est pas encore gagné mais en tout cas
un peu mieux pour westle des il a du bol
de pas être perdant là B5 il a du
bol un cavalier5 il faut de toute façon
ça attaque le K F3 donc oui ça paraît
logique et après probablement qu'il veut
t'échanger en G2 et peut-être
faire dame B2 qui C4 jeais même qu'un
coup comme k F5 peut-être que D4
dispasse contre B5 et tu es mieux avec
les blancs mais va bloquer mais il faut
s'ouffrir avec le No c'est pas c'est pas
fait faut réussisse à jouer là il avec
tour 3 je pense mais 3 j'y crois pas
trop jou t à 4
direct B2
probablement regarder un il sur ce pion
D4 je CIS qu'
va il va la
tenir pas grave jolie partie d B2 par
Wesley
retard de 20 secondes on rappelles ont 3
secondes par coup ça
va prob pr C4 Bou C4 bouff C4 D1 C3
bouffe C3 bouffe D4 bouff D4 bouffe D4
et peut-être a roi G2 à la fin ce que je
en train de calculer sur quelle ligne tu
fais fais C4 non là maintenant des noir
ouais tu le
bouffes on
prend prend les deux après Bou D4 il bou
bou bou bou ça va être nul hein c'est
Lig que j'avais c'est la ligne que
j'avais peut-être prend
d5e façon xou y tu arriv à ça al attends
si tu as le temps de faire tour au 3
tour C3 t tour 3 tour F3
pardon
tu as pas le
temps tour qui reste en l'air
malheureusement ça pe être simple pour
les blancs de faire le moindre progrès
en fait c 4 bien placé qui bloque
tout donc il y avait pas de d prend
échec
là il a pas mass de casen fait g
H3 5
d'abord pas4 calier de
N3 du
coup7 je pas s qu'on AC
grandchose
B3 on vaer ce en plus mais qui sera
bloqué par les deux
tours
dore pas
[Musique]
mal il bien
jouou4
joume mais pant ce temps les n on le
temps d'activer les rois d'avancer de
monter le RO aussi c'est sûr que tu vas
faire roi f32 roi D2 roi C2 roi B2 B2
tour B3 tour
B4 mais d'illeur peut-êtrechange pas les
dames en
fait
pas je sais pas pourquoi il a pas pris
tempo un
tour 8 un truc comme
ça dur considérer quoi surtout oui il y
avait le truc en A5 en l'air aussi c'est
pour ça il y avait dame pr 5
aussi il y av aussi dame prend à 5 G5
direct qu'on se déjà fixé la drit H5
sûrement pe-être un tour4
ici j'ai
de
pas de choix il changer j'imagine
tour4ance plus pas
grandose B le temps d'avaner ça perd
même je pense tu vas loin
là-bas
ten les échecs
mett le r
D3 F3 et ça va plus
bouger très belle partie là belle pass
d'arme
ouais éche bien
joué c'est quandme mieux quand ça joue
bien il vatir vers
A4
ça va répéter à
priori très belle passe d'arme match nul
bravo messieurs et on se retrouve Fabien
après la pause à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les amis qui par l'anglaise C4 par
5 classique alors à voir comment magn
jou' va jouer avec un K avec E3
ou4 on voir
les 4 cavaliers donc j'ai3 principal
mais3 jouable4 D4 A3 plein de petit coup
ici cavalier g
oui alors ça c'est quand on fin d'aren
faire pour Marquand Mme des points avant
la fin de mais sinon je ne recommanderai
pas ce coup dans d'utres
circonstances qui réfléchit en tout cas
FA
G3 bon ben le coup classique D5 prise
cavalier prend fou G2 de sicilienne à
l'envers tout à fait alors pendant
longtemps la grande ligne c'était qui B6
il y eu gritchou qui introd fou C5 et
puis on a vu aussi des joueurs jouer
avec cavalier F6 ici ah bah voilà
cavalier F6 puis H6 d'apparence modeste
mais bon ça va
quoi après tout vain oui oui mais je
veux dire ça c'est un coup il y a encore
un an de ça
ouais après c'est prait pour un idiot de
jouer ça quoi ouais après ordi ordi ordi
ça me fait penser là en ce moment ils te
font truc les tous sur D4 le truc de le
CO Game c'est insupportable des4 C3 là
non euh alors ils te font plein de des4
C3 et ils te font aussi sur le système
de Londres ils t'ont fait le cours de le
CO game à fond hein système de Londres
c'est quelle ligne je suis pas ligne
avec dam le truc avec fou F5 la machin
le pion qui
sacrifie5 il me saouleent avec leur
ligne je sais pas de quelle ligne on
parle en fait donc c'est de le coang
Game peu importe mais en fait d dès
qu'il se mett tous à jour un truc il y a
eu un cours de chass bal quoi non le
coangame a fait un cours cheassable
sur sur euh sur le système deondre avec
les Blancs où il fait en fait D4 D5 k F3
qui F6
C3 je crois et euh ah ouais donc ça il a
fait ah euh mais je savais pas qu'il
faisait un truc avec les Noirs aussi du
coup
je sa pas c'est peut-être un autre je
sais rien de qui fait quoi mais ce qui
est sû c'est que c'est devenu
insupportable dès qu'il y en a un qui
sort un cours il te met tous le faire
quoi
mais Copin enfin c'est ouais bon
ouais c'est vraiment pas l'échec que
j'aime je sais pas réfléchissez un peu
par vous-même au se répéter comme des
perroquets mais bon faut dire que c'est
efficace et et que bah c'est l'évolution
qui est comme ça et c'est la vie
hein en tout cas il te fait
le le cavalier F6
H6 ça je suis pas sûr qu'il a un cour
dessus pour le coup
mais ça ne saurait tarder à mon
avis après c'est vrai que le K F6 c'est
pas forcément beaucoup plus mal qu'en
B6 Magnus qui faire un double fionketo
et probablement avec ce fou B2 essayer
de faire D4 à un moment pour ouvrir la
position
pas de petite nul pour le
moment Magnus qui hier soir était à
Toronto avec les bras en match de
ok j'ai vu bon il a bien raison hein ça
doit être très
sympa
est-ce que tu penses c'était une soirée
arrosée ça peut après il peut pas bon
ilandme un match très important à jouer
aujourd'hui donc peut-être un ver ou de
ou zé et il arrosera à la fin du tournoi
je ne sais
pas mais ça pourrait c'est pas hors de
propos que ça le soit
hein
bon après le coup je j'ai l' de principe
serait de faire
E4 E1 défendre ce pion les BL lucass
avec F3 ou D3 ou
quoi en tout cas il fait fou D6 ouais
bon ça c'est conservateur mais pas bête
sur mon fou B2 et essayer de jouer des
qu avec les Blancs
euh ça semble la suite logique vu le
développement choisi par par Magnus avec
ce coupe
B3 donc pas du tout qu' B5 je suppose
ouais bon ce serait pas non plus
débileon pe même juste laisser le fou
bah je pense qu'il le laisserait ouis il
reprend C pour
renforceru sa voix d'aujourd'hui le
Magnus a dû en prendre des cuites c'est
possible he parce que je crois qu'il
aime bien quand même faire de belle
sortie
Magnus j'imagine mal aller voir un match
de
nhhel nhhl est pas un petit peu en
profiter après il a raison il est dans
une phase dans sa carrière où il s'amuse
he
Magnus rien à prouver à
personne mais il a peut-être pas abusé
quoi non je pense pas non parce qu'il a
pas l'air trop mal là je dire tu ah
sinon tu le verrais suer la grosse
goutte le temp
[Musique]
palichon de trois shots et puis c'est
tout hein peut-être qu'il a juste crié
comme un fou furieux dans
le dans l'enceinte
dansenceinte je pense
c'est les mapples peut-être de
Toronto pourquoi
pas aucune idée je suis ent pas
doncux le donner le long que tu veux je
te
croirais les male
le je te dire ça de ce pasble
ouais les map de Toronto
exactement qui ont perdu hier en
prolongation 6 à 5 contre les Blue
Jackets l'armagon du coup on en chéri
sur la distance de tir il avait 5 buts
d'avance tues tu per 65 c'est moche non
il men 5- ils sont égalisés ils ont
gagné 65 ah oui d'accord c'est dommage
quand tu fais une t remont tu crois
quoi la dynamique avec
toi je sais pas comment j'ai sorti les
map en fait je sais pas pourquoi je le
sais je sais pas non plus mais peut-être
tu as vu un poste où c'était dit et C
reste en tête j'ai dû le savoir il y a
un moment en fait parce que je regardais
un peu de NHL dans un moment ah
d'accordok les Blue jacket il viennent
d'où
Colombus don quoi au classement ça se
passe quand même plutôt bien pour les
Mapple lefes qui sont deè la conférence
Atlantique j'aime bien les Detroit Red
Wings une belle
équipe les Blue jacket ils sontèement
derniers de la division métropolitaine
quoi il do être très heureux d'avoir
gagné hier
ouais beau sport beau sport j'aimais
bien le Hok quand j'étais petit enfin je
suis jamais all en voir au stade ou quoi
mais je me souviens je suivais les
gios les j de 94 ou quoi et le Canada
qui é est bon la
Suède la France on toujours été un peu
nul non on est pas un pays de bâtin noir
hein globalement B même de patinoir quoi
on est bon dans aucun sport de
patinoir artistique on a eu bon bon
patineur patineuse ici ou là on c'est
pas le sport le plus non bah
non le truc que personne ne veut
vraiment faire bon on est là mais mais
patinage de vitesse on est
mauvais c'est pour ça que les pièces de
Max NT pas assez glissé à Toronto pas
gestuelle
adapté son fou5 pour contester ce fou B2
F la star pour l'instant de cette
finale à chaque
partieou aux échecs
curling tu ASAS bien viser pour que ta
s'arrête sur la bonne case si tu vas
trop loin tu es éliminé enfin ta pièce
dégage du jeu tu vas pas assez loin bon
ça va mais tu j un coup un peu de merde
quand même
ouais du coup tu peux peut-être laisser
des mats du couloir en disant bon il n
ara
pas après il bal à
fond je CIS que ça marche vraiment bien
le truc de B non mais faut être un bon B
l'illeur quoi puis je pense que selon la
force du du tir tu l'as pas Billé pareil
quoi
c'est
sûr en l'ffet aussi ouais c'est pas
juste Ballé au hasard quoi je pense
c'est moi j'ai des potes à mcou qui des
fois all les jouer au
curling j'ai je voulais y aller puis je
jamais tombé dessus mais ils m'ont
toujours dit que c'était très
marrant mais tu as toute une technique
dans le dans le jeté dans la
rotation exactement ouais tu mets de
l'effet quoi sors pas tout droit
bêtement quoi non non non pas du
tout V facile je sais pas mais je crois
que c'est vraiment un sport
difficile mais ce serait beau pour les
échecs la fou 5 c'est un coup pas très
dur à jouer mais bon tu as placé
beaucoup de pierres un peu de
partout si tu vas un peu trop loin tu F4
c'est un peu
dommage
age de vitesse aussi qui est un beau
sport mais je crois qu'on est nul à tout
[Musique]
en sur glace enin à part le C artistique
mais jeir Micha sinon on n'est pas on n
pas très
bon
bêtis mais ok sur glass on a un très bon
gardien de but en
France les gens doivent connaître dans
le chat j'ai plus son nom mais je sais
qu'on on avait un des meilleurs gardiens
de but du monde ah c'est c'est le poste
le plus important en plus sur un terrain
de hockey à j'aurais bien jouer gardien
C je parce que je sais pas patiner donc
là je me dis bon je reste dans mes cases
j'ai ma miain et je faises j'essaie
d'avoir des réflexes pour arrêter les
les palais quoi je pense c'est dur comme
avec ma crossse et
tout
bon Magnus qui a réfléchi qui a pris
quand même du retard à la
pendule relativement serein jusqu'à
présent dans cette
partie
quiespère pouvoir offrir du ton à schat
on rappelle tout l'enjeu de cette cette
finale le pris en FC j'imagine a une
unique sur un poster displate de haute
qualité signé par les deux finalistes
réservé le vôre dès maintenant il y aura
quand même plusieurs éditions il y aura
pas que un bon il y en aura pas
énormément quoi ça pe être sympa
ou christobalé ouais je crois qu'il est
vraiment très fort
qui est en train de s'aplanir Fabien
ouais alors les blanc auraient bien aimé
aller chasser s F6 avec un coup 4 D5
mais cétait s'exposer un coup comme
cavalier F3 et donc il d'abord E3 le
cavalier qui peut repartir soit en E6 g
E6 à priori moi mais peut-être même C6
mais je mettrai plutôt le C E6 un pion
en C6 si besoin bien bloquer ce F
G2 et aussi le K faut dire qu'il pourra
rebondir vers la case C5 etut vers D3
plus tard attaque un peu le pion B3
donc je jai plutôt de la sorte alors
après peut-être qu'ilch un coup
B5 voir ce que ça
donne il réfléchit mais je pense que la
position va s'aplagir et il va filer
vers la nulle ce qui nous approchera
encore un petit peu plus d'un Armagedon
ah oui on en rêve on en rêve
aujourd'hui sera une journée un petit
peu courte malheureusement on va pas
finirant après 22h ça m'étonnerait quoi
ou alors quand même hier on s délecté
jusqu'à
min30 pour la finale ils auraient pu
jouer en 37 gagnant pour pour moi après
2 7 aujourd'hui c'est ce que je pensais
ouais parce quand même un niveau
auudessus des demis donc
finir au moins di au cas où un TR un 5e
set de tous les dangers
dimanche ça la pothéose de ce tournoi
oui ça aurit pu être une solution après
c'est pas celle qui a été
retenue à notre grand regret bon c'est
quand même un très grand succès ce
tournoi malgré tout donc on avit
peut-être pas besoin d'aller jusque là
mais bon on aurait bien aimé parce que
parce que quel spectacle on a dans cette
finale quoi complètement
Fabien al heureusement c'était pas du
goût des organisateurs pr il faut
prendre à8 sur fou B2 et peut-être A4
pour er ce pion simplifier les règles il
va essayer un coup comme tour D3
simplement pour aller gagner le pion
B fou B2 ça pe être facile de tout
garder envie côté noir côté blanc pour
ça que veut faire
B4 prend à 3 B prend à 5 F B4 qui est B6
F prend à 5 prise C8 prise C8 prise B7
et puis un pion de moins mais plus rien
sur les
chiquers on peut même faire mieux ENIT
on peut faire FO 3 prise fou B4 qui6 fou
bouge fou prend B7 fou prend A5 tu as
quand même la paire de fou encore et
oui bon proposer ça doit aller quand
même avec tous les pions sur la même
aelle et
euh après B4 c'est un coup responsable
hein par si tu laisse A4 quand même au
noir enfin bon ilement qui B6 qui le
choper ou quoi
mais 3 essayie ce machin ouais ça c'est
une ligne très clean ouais on va plus en
entendre parler pendant très longtemps
de cette partie donc la in clean de
faire fou pr à 3 pour les Noirs ça parat
logique les blancs prennent en C8 on
reprend il gagne le pion B7 et là tour
c'est important échange la tour qui
était le seul danger et les f reposé bon
permettent de faire il y en a une dans
la slave d'échange qui est pas si simple
c'est celle où tu as en fait tu aurais
pas a 5 et pas E3 et tu aurais un P
quand même un pion alors est nul quand
même mais il faut faire att le Roi peut
aller il peut se passer des choses est
vraiment facile c'est d'ailleurs la
partie je sais pas s'il vont faire nul
direct si Magnus va prétendre jouer mais
là il y a vraiment aucun risque aucun
risque de rien ou d'ailleurs je mettrais
bien mon r E7 et les pions en G6 H5 sur
les couleurs adverses
pour les
échanger tu peux jouer comme
ça ni ve ro G7 F5 j'imagine
ouais bon partie belle partie encore ça
joue mieux ça joue réellement nettement
mieux cette finale alors c'est une
partie où il y aura pas eu énormément
d'histoire celle-là mais c'est parce que
c'est des parties qualitatives c'est ce
qu'on attendait depuis le début du
tournoi en fait c'est le niveau de jeu
qui semblait être attendu et normal pour
des joueurs de de ce
calibre mais c'est que ça n'a pas bien
joué pendant pendant
longtemps
et là
enfin on arrive au niveau qui est le
leure je déjà mettre un partout le score
vous
m'excuserez je prends un
risque j'affiche déjà le score qui aura
la fin de cette
partie partie effac par
les position c'est un pour les blancs
mais quasi impossible de faire un pion
passer quand bien même il y aura un pion
sera il serait bloqué sur une case noire
qui serait intouchable et et donc
voilà pas trop d'histoire
[Musique]
là-dedans moi je préfère personnellement
avoir des belles parties comme ça même
si ça fait nul et puis de temps en temps
des apothéos que des parties avec des
gaffes tout le temps enfin au moment
j'enis plus en
fait genre là tu as des vraies parties
quoi ouais non mais sûr enfin je suis
d'accord enfin on veut que ça joue bien
le mieux possible disons s'il y a des
erreurs elle soit explicable je veux
bien qu' genre sur les quatre parties en
a une à un moment donné o soit un peu
l'apthéos que les deux se sont mis en
SPR question et que il y en a un qui
craque et c'est normal mais là cétait
n'importe quoi tout le temps ça jouit
tempo oua ça faisait tout le temps là ok
même enfin je préfère avoir trois
parties comme ça enfin comme les deux
premières une trè encore comme ça et une
4è o
finalementoum sur la gueule que que ce
qu'on a un peu suivi jusqu'à maintenant
ou tu avais l'impression quasiment de
jouer des de regarder des bits de title
tuday ENF j'exagère un petit peu mais
non FO même mieux chez
certains
voilà après moi c'estes parti là je suis
jamais partisan de que ça joue beaucoup
qu ça s'arrête vite Magnus qui essaye
après mais je sais pas ce qu'il essayie
en fait je vois aucun
scénario si tu avais un piège un truc
mais là il y a rien
quoi prendre h
ou pas y arriver bah non enfin
essayer de trer h contre croist pas dro
proposer nul
aussi ont le droit donc petite nul mais
très jolie partie donc bravo au deux
hommes pour cette belle passe d'armes et
on se retrouve très bientôt pour la
suite des aventures et les deux
dernières parties de la journée à tout
suite les
gar how about now manage your air
quality sharpen your performance change
the game with air things a new opening
for your wall is here capture new major
pieces on unique metal posters from
displate now with the official
collection from chest.com Mount them in
seconds with a toolfe magnet kit and
swap them whenever you like make your
move get an exclusive discount on all
metal posters shop now with the code
chess at displate.com
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est reparti c'est reparti mesdames et
messieurs
pour ce match palpitant et le petit coup
à auokell alors svent les blancs font
soit C4 so C3 c'est moins bien rputé
d'ouvrir avec D4 là-dessus donc C3 bien
connu et bien
C4 après on peut faire C3 pour
temporiser aussi faire B4 aussi ah ça
ouais je m'attends pas ce que Wesley
joue un tel coup il a double s pièces
pour le moment il est bien il pense à s
ch je
pense quel coup jouer pour pouvoir le
offrir une boîte de
thon G3 peut-être il va faire
Westley A4
oui donc D4 pas ouf pourquoi parce que
pu on prend cavalier prend cavalier F6 C
C3 et E5 et on a plus de C B5 et les
Noirs vont faire fou B4 qui va arriver
D5 qui part et il prennent déjà le
centre et bon donc un peu un peu relou
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle des4
on aaime pas
trop la
Kelli
donc une varante irlandaise
ouais je suis même pas sûr qu' éta
irlandais mais son nom est irlandais
bien
sûr F
de'intéresse
pas Magus qui peut jouer E6 et à ce
momentlà RET dans une sienne E6 comm il
a jouer contre Fabiano j'imagine que tu
peux jouer jou D6 peut-être
aussi mais j'ir j'irai sur E6
H6 pourqu ne pas jouer un coup comme
cavalier C6
ouais peut-être D4 à ce momentl
ou rock et garder des4 pour la suite
déjà c'est déjà complètement n'importe
quoi la partie ça fait plaisir mais
c'est pas mal joué mais c'est fa ass
pour le sur pr je suis fou de
tiens c'est assez
marrant non mais fou de j'aime j'aime
assez c'est un coup bah qui para de
roquer on mais pas le fou n'importe où
il y a trop d'amateurs qui a mal en C4
quoi qui se passe mais tu te prends B5
et puis puis voilà bon ben ça va
peut-être transposer juste dans une nage
d'orf avec fou 2 s'il prend du cavalier
qui a F6 k C3 il va peut-ê faire F3 pe
faire dame pr aussi
Wesley je te contre surprends sur C6
dame 3 ouais bon je ferai pas hein mais
ouais tu peux
h il le fait on PEI faire K6 dame D2
peut-être
je le sens aller en E3 mais oui tu peux
aller en
D2 pour faire B3 ensuite
ouais mais je pense il va faire dame 3
petit
rock
on a le droit de toucher ces pièces au
début de oui si tu dis jadou avant en
fait c'est un peu
le jadou c'est un peu le mot magique si
tu
veux il pièce touché pièce à jouer c'est
si tu touches une pièce tu as rien dit
ah bah il faut jouer faut la jouer mais
si tu as dit jadou avant ça veut dire tu
comptes juste repositionner la pièce et
tu n'as pas l'intention de la jouer mais
il faut bien verbaliser ton attitude ton
attention et à ce momentl tout va
bien même en anglais tu dis j'adoube
dans le texte alors est-ce que tu peux
dire i replace my pieces adjust je c adj
ouais cracher ça sonne Mo bien que un GR
mard il n pas dit jadou il baraguiné un
truc dans sa
langue est-ce qu'il y a des arbitres qui
peuvent nous donner un peu la règle pour
ça jadou enfin est-ce que c'est est-ce
qu'il a des termes précis qui sont
autorisés si un étranger il connait pas
jadou il dit euh
tu
perd tu dois jouer ta
pièce qu' préfère la dame en
D3 pourquoi pas au passage hein et donc
ça va ressembler à la partie
précédente même structure le C F3 euh
ouais
peut-être jouer quand même C4 ùel ça
peut être l'idée hein de jouer une sorte
de d't maroxy mais bon C4 il y a quand
même fou G4 qui donc peut-être tu dois
d'abord faire
H3 pas laisser le fou venir t'échanger
ton cavalier vu qu'avec C4 tu vas quand
même affaiblir un petit peu quand même
les cases noires POS une question est-ce
que tu as le droit de dire jadou puis de
balancer les Chiquet par terre
probablement
probablement mais il faudra remettre les
pièces après sur ton propre
temps c'est déjà arrivé ça l'air de
faire tomber un échiti en partie bon
probablement j'ai jamais vu un de mes
propres yeux mais je veux dire j'ai
tellement eu de parties et d'histoire de
partout sur la planète que ça a dû
arriver de faire tomber les Chiers ou de
faire tomber la pendule ou de faire
tomber plein de choses l'adversaire
aussi il y a il y un gars qui était
tombé tu avais vu la vidéo je sais plus
ah il tombé de sa chaise ou il était là
et l'autre jou un coup et ouais ouais
j'avais vu j'avisu effectivement ça me
dit quelque chose exceptionnelle cette
vidéodote très
croustillante c'est une vidéo assez
marrante par tellement surpris par le
coup B C D5 donc il veut jouer comme un
ét de maroxy dans l'esprit même si joue
sans C4 en fait c'est pour reprendre de
et jouer sur la faiblesse en c'est4 un
jour mais là bon peut-être
G5 moi parler de C3 j'aime bien C3 parce
que
c'est fou tiens je te construis un petit
mur petit TIG Glou en
face bon j'imagine que il a envie de
poursuivre par par fou G5 s'il peut ou F
E3 hein Fab parce que tu peux vouloir
aussi
oui mais en fait en gros le scénario
probable c'est que les Noirs vont
t'éliminer D5 tu reprends de du coup le
5 fait déjà pression
sur7 donc à Magnus de jouer il fait B5
ouais donc là plutôt fou G5 c'est
sûr
c'est pas contre procian le mec qui
tombe
si ça peut être contre
pétrroan mais c'est une vidéo récente
ouis le PIP Pampers
ouais mais ça chite est mémorable c'est
tellement beau il a tourner son cavalier
ou son
truc ilose en
plein
une routine quand c'est à notre tour
coup de l'adversaire fourchette de Caval
un truc vous faites à chaque fois ah je
crois pas non et quand on réfléchi
je suis pas trop sûr après
tu si tu as le temps hein que c'est une
partie un peu lente avant de jouer tu
souffles 2 secondes c'est devoir dans un
œil neuf si tu as pas juste loupé un
truc complètement débile et évident que
tu fous une pièce en prise qu' a mat en
un que tu étais tellement pris dans tes
pensées
mais mais bon non il y a pas de grande
routine à faire après ce qui est bizarre
c'est que très souvent en parti t
adversaires il jouent pas du tout ce que
tu é en train de calculer
ouais B il joue mal
quoi et toi aussi au moment où tu viens
de jouer tuas tu as l'impression que tu
vois plein d'idées supplémentaires c'est
un peu des fois tu joues puis ouais tu
pas regarder des
trucs ça
numéro l'ordi c'est fou G5 norm
F5 je vouis pas wel logique petit pull
vert
aujourd'hui qu'on appelle le caca Doig
non un petit peu ouais non mais c'est
une logique5 tu mets une pression sur le
kf6 tu menaces de prendre et de doubler
les pions donc les Noirs devraent r agir
soit faire7 soit prend D5 après c'est
c'est leur
choix mais tu les forces en fait
finalement à prendre UNEC
des7 ça te dérange pas trop quand même
même si c'est probablement un coup
jouable au demeurant mais bon et qu'
prend des 5 B moins tu prends du pion et
puis puis
voilà propose cavalier A5 comme coup
principal mais bon j'ai l'impression que
tu prends bah ouais ouais tu es mieux
c'est tout i il est heureux de ça mais
il est heure de rien enfin mais
peut-être un ordi je peux pas discuter
mais jai comme ça je serai tu je tombe
de ma chaise moi voilà mag prix quoi ce
qui est normal donc on reprend du pion
là voilà on souvre la colonne E on va
continuer par tour1 pas tout de suite là
on va échanger
et alors question oui est-ce que je peux
tenter F4 dis F G7 F5 et donner la
qualité ouais bah
calculer c'est forcé en dame C8 est fort
peut-être
F5 de toute façon pour fermer les
écoutilles mais il faut c'est des quoi
regarder ça c'est des quoi regarder on
peut affablir le roi mais sinon bon
juste tour1 tour F1
A4 H4
ouais peut-être plus tard j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu tôt mais
bon c'est peut-être
jouable j'aime mieux la position blanche
dame E4 avecidé dame H4 tu pourrais tu
pourrais A4
oui A4 prend tour pr et T H4 double idée
Tu attaqu à 6 tu veux aller ver H4
peut-être donc à 4 j'aime bien
probablement que devrait ne pas trop
toucher D7 truc ça mais du coup tu es
content bah après faudra prendre ou
faire A5 fixer
pas mal
direct
entreprenant j'aime bien H4
aussi H5 c'est une vraie menace que si
tu arrive jusqu'en
[Musique]
H6
de te faiter
non tu suis un peu quand
même B non moi je suis pour Wes en fait
donc je suis très heureux
ouais mais tu tu vois le scénario de
l'armaganon s'éloigner un petit peu
ou loin d'être sûr déjà bon je suis
quand même assez satisfait on aa minimum
quatre parties
aujourd'hui si pour une fois il y a pas
d'armagedon bon bien sûr ce serait
dommage mais on perd pas espoir pour
demain de peut-être en vivre un ou deux
donc voilà si pour une fois on se couche
un peu plus
tôt F5 été jouer il se développe il
attaque la dame on pensera un coupre
comme dame F3 dame D2 aussi possible
bien joué il esquive cette menace et il
veut jouer H5
ou peut-être pousser tout le monde
G4 ou je me disais ça commencer par G4
comme ça sur 4 F3 puis après
F4 F5 dégagez tous
quoi en fait j'a bien par qu' cl je vois
pas ce que tu peux faire non pas trop de
plan avec tu subis ce qui se
passe tu es assez solide mais bon ça
peut mal se passer j'irais faire à
4 tu as joué vraiment bien en tout cas
dans ce tourno dans cette finale oui
dans cette finale côté
sa il fou D3
doncè échanger ce fou pr ser de faire F4
F5 mais Magnus renforce cas Blanes a
coup
Go qu' a raté W mais il gagne pas un
pion il gagne un pion mais c'est
peut-être pas
passionnant bon un pion est un pion hein
il va aller le chercher c'est
sûr c'est bien joué si c'est pas
ouais il va s'activer tu ve
dire
ouais c'est tenant du titre on oublié de
le
rappeler très régulier hein dans ces
tournois
ouais l' dernier Magnus n'it pas
participé he il avait d'autres chats à
fouetter et l'an dernier c'était en
présentiel la finale ou pas al ça devait
être en présentiel mais a des joueurs
qui avent pas reçu de visa ah oui c'est
vrai ils avaient pas pu fa à deux
endroits différent donc ça jouit depuis
les domiciles non ils avaient ça jou
depuis Belgrade et certains étaient allé
jouer à Belgrade c'est ça Douda je crois
ouais il y avait des sarines peut-être
des Indiens je sais plus peu importe
mais il y avait ça se jou à deux
endroits en même temps et c'est pour ça
que c'était jouer sur ordinateur oui
très différent mais déjà mieux que si
les joueurs sont domicile bien sûr plus
sécurisant quand même c'était Westley
qui l'avait emporté déjà éliminant
ikarou Naka ma en
demi-finale cette année ikarou n'est pas
allé aussi loin très très tôt dans le
tournoi au dépit de ces
fans des fans qui ont eu le seum on peut
le
dire
éliminé on peut dire en quart de finale
en quelque sorte quelque sorte mais sans
BR non r tout
r C'est Magnus l'an dernier il a gagné
quoi SPE je sais pas il gagné quoi alors
cétait il y a 2 ans
alors il y a tellement de tourno après
on
oublie mais c'est le truc qui eu svant
te rappelles pas s machin si si je me
souviens un truc comme çaant que tu en
parles mais c pas l'an dernier ça qu'on
avait vu le match entre so et Sarine o
il jou des mod
mais je comter à distance d'ailleurs
j'étais avec toi mais mais pas
d'ici j'essie de me rappeler en
fait je peux taper sur internet un petit
peu aller voir un petit peu autre
tournoi
alors champion chez tour 2023 déjà 202
pardon ça devit être un autre tournoi je
dire une bêtise mais c'est vrai qu'il y
en a tellement que au bout d'un moment
on les confond
avec les mêmes participants donc et non
c'était le champion du monde Magnus
Carlson qui
remporté alors c'était joué comment ce
truc je vais voir sur Wikipédia un petit
peu ce qu'ils on disent céit peut-être
la finale du Rapid chess Championship
alors l'an dernier peut-être le Rapid
chess classement final c'était Magnus
Carlsen douudda 2 pragananda 3e le
kangliem anich Guiri le wi que l'an
dernier il y avait encore les deux
circuits c'est ça mais en fait celui-là
c'est plus il a plus comment dire la
finale celleà ressemble plus au ah oui
c'était le truc ça y est je me rappelle
où pragananda avait bien joué où il y
avait une Iman c'est ça il y avait une
Iman 17e voilà c'est ça mais qui avait
tout perdu en phase finale tu te
rappelles pas oua
ou en public
c'est vrai que l' dernier avait les deux
tournois et donc était tenant du ce truc
qui était joué juste avant
laield il bien fait déboitter devant
tout le monde comme ça
après et l'autre c'était le circuit ch
mais qui ont un peu fusionné quoi entre
guillemets c'est un peu les deux
champions des de circuits qui France de
l'an dernier
le Gota des chiquen dans ce
format est-ce que finalement cette
fusion play Magnus chesscom ne coûte pas
aux joueurs qui ont moins de tournois
finalement avec
c'est vrai que c'est dommage
plus de tournois cette année dans ce Tru
là aussi du coup bon Lesme très beau et
l'an dernier c'est vrai qu'il n'y avait
que 1,6 million dans le champion gestor
quand même on
a mis beaucoup plus de budget il a déjà
1ion5 juste sur la finale
ouais puis toutes les phases de pou plus
il aura aussi je pense Magnus qui va
remporter la série entière avec les
points qui prend un petit bonus de
100000 donc du 100000 en plus ouis dans
la
besace et ça
c'est la question se pose en tout cas on
espère que l'an prochain l'an prochain
je crois qu'il y aura que cinq tournois
mais le prix seront
similaires déjà plus rentable un peu en
quantité de temps investi on espère
quand même que le spectacle sera au
moins autant au
rendez-vous donc il y aura quatre
tournois tout au long de l'année puis
une une phase finale et ça tu peux nous
donner les dates Fabien ah oui tout à
fait j'ai déjà pris date hein je je me
suis renseigné je me suis dit que je ne
comptais pas rater ça euh notamment la
la grande finale les phases avant on
verra alors ça reprend très tôt dès le
31 janvier jusqu'au 7 février le premier
événement du champion chest tour les
joueurs vont souffler un petit peu et ça
reprendra du 8 au 15 mai juste après les
candidats donc comme ça on sera en
pleine VO donc j'espère peut-être pour
commentter avec toi il y aura l'été
aussi du 17 au 24 juillet là encore
pourquoi pas ça on pourra le faire aussi
ensemble le 4è t très important pour
peut-être les dernières places
qualificatives qui sera du 25 septembre
au 2 octobre c'est là que Maxime avait
obtenu finalement dans ce dernier
dernier événement 4e et puis bah la
grande finale du 14 au 21 des dates
similaires à cette année une semaine
plus tard quand même est-ce que ça sera
encore à
Toronto ça je sais pas mais ce qui fait
plaisir Fabien c'est que c'est un
tournoi qui s'installe et av les dates
du speed aussi ah oui oui oui mais je
peuxetrouver TNO qui s'installe dans
l'année donc on aura tous les ans là en
décembbr le double ce tournoant rapide
avec énormément d'argent puis le
championnat du monde de Blitz c'est
rapide ser une semain sur donc speed
c'est ce que tu as les les dates
c'est du 25 juillet au 9 FO ou al là
palpitant parce que il y aurait un grand
un champion chestour du 17 au 24 juillet
tu dors un petit peu tu te réveilles dès
le 25 le speedchess démarre le speedess
qui commence donc le 25 juillet le
lendemain jusqu'au 9 août c'est
extraordinaire ah ben c'est
extraordinaire oui c'est vraiment
superbe et puis peut-être bon al là bon
il serait possible d'enchaîner le
speitch junior les talents de demain du
8 au 12 tu as quand même 5 jours de
pause non en juillet tu bon tu as 5
jours de pause tu es un peu déçu tu as
rien à voir mais bon c'est l'été
peut-être tu peux imp Tour de France bon
par désœuvrement tu as vraiment rien
d'autre à faire et puis tout d'un coup
paf tuenchaînes champion chest tour et
speed chess tu passes vraiment un été
incroyable est-ce qu'il a pas encore
plus d'enchaîner
sûrement que si il y a
des
ah mais tu speed champion finale 7 au 8
septembre encore plus loin d'accord
c'est mais oua non c juste une capture
j'ai pas le bat de page mais déjà
vraiment des beaux événements que nous
tu auras le woman SPE Championship du 26
au 30 donc oui tuas tu peux faire un
été et les Olympi ça tombe quand les
Olympiad d'échec alors ça c'est une
information qui tu peut nous nous donner
aussi beaucoup moins important tu sais
les Olympiades par rapport quandême C
tournoi
qualitatif je suis en train de dire un
truc est-ce qu'on peut faire tour prend
tour prend pion prend tour prend tour 8
tour 6
bam du 10 au 22 septembre ben oui voilà
les Olympiades qui sont décalés quand
même pour laisser la primeur de l'été à
à tous ces tournois euh alors est-ce
qu'il y aurait pas un speed chest finals
en même temps mais ça que tu pourras
enchaîner les Olympiades et juste juste
après on aura le la 4e étape ouis voilà
il commence je crois fin septembre ah
ouais non mais ça veut dire qu'on va
avoir une année encore sous le signe des
échecs ça c'est génial on va avoir des
tournois toutes les toutes les semaines
parce que là on vous a parlé que de ces
TR mais on peut aussi vous donner les
les dates si vous voulez le allons plus
loin hein du Grand chest tour aussi
grand chestour un peu dépassé maintenant
par ces tournois mais quand même qu'on
aime bien suivre qui était la la grande
révolution des 10 dernières années dans
les échecs ça a complètement modifié
notre perception du jeu euh et euh et
donc ce grand GESTOUR qui continue on
est quand même déçu d'avoir perdu notre
tournoi parisien mais alors on aura
quand même un
tournoi je pense alors oui dat du 6 au
oh du 6 au 13 mai est-ce que ce serait
pas pendant le si si y il y en a un qui
P le 8 8 au 15 il y aura du 25 juint au
6 juillet alors là ce sera bien c'est en
décaléis du 8 juillet au 15 juillet oh
là là là Fabien oui et du 10 au au 17
août et du 17 août au 31 aïe aïe a a
mais du 8 au 15 juillet c'est bon gr ça
commence le 17 ou le 18 donc là c'est
bon les enchaîner le grand chest tour
Croatie et tout de suite bien sûr bien
se connecter et jouer le champion de
chest
tour donc ouais le Grand chestour qui
qui a un petit peu muté quand même ces
dernières années ils ont plus d'étapes
ni en Côte d'Ivoire ni en France
euh mais ils ont gardé varsau Bucharest
Zagreb et Saint-Louis la S field Cup
pour finir en apoé on mais du coup ça ça
ça se touche pas on est d'accord hein
c'est du 6 8 au 15 l'autre c'est bien en
fait ils se sont mis d'accord avec avec
le grand chess ça c'est une excellente
nouvelle pour tous les fans d'échec on
met ça se touche je crois pardon c'est
que je crois justement qu'ils enchaînent
Bam Bam Bam Bam du 8 au 15 voilà c'est
ça du 6 au ils sont en plein clash
comment comment va-t-on
faire mais tu sais je crois que dans et
en juillet non en juillet c'est bon là
il on 8 15 tu es sûr ouais ouais ils ont
bien mis le 17 ou 18 là c'est bon mais
c'est possible que comme les G ne
doivent pas forcément toutes les phases
du Grand chest tour
ah puiss un peu décaler je sais pas faud
peut-être faire des choix mais c'est
c'est dommage comment va faire oui mais
et en août alors le ah le speedch
Championship ne tombe pas pendant le
Saint-Louis rapide il y a que le le le
Polon
ouais c'est un peu un dilemme je pense
pour des joueurs de tennis qui aimerait
pouvoir jouer et stutgard et le Queens
par exemple avant wiblon et là bon le
c'est mal fa en même temps il nous dis
ils vont pre pendant les jours ah B ça
va être à fond pendant les j là ça va
être s fout des j les qui pass aessus
des
j partie qui continue pour le moment bon
c'est ça a l'air plus ou moins égal mais
c'est vra qu'on parlait de ce calendrier
magnifique c'est et bon et à ça faudra
encore ajouter la proess leag on a pas
parlé t mineur certes mais mais bon les
candidats quand même pour passer le
temps et attendre un peu que le le le
festival commence à partir de mais ça t
extraordinaire on un premier trimestre
un petit peu compliqué ouais puis on va
commencer à monter en puissance avec un
petit TR donc les candidats on pourra
quelque part
euh bouche et puis après on va enchaîner
c'est un peu comme un un Dauphiné Libéré
quoi c'est pas mal ça pas la la l'éclat
d'un tour de France mais c'est bien quo
on peut un peu juger les les forces en
présence donc voil un petit peu donc les
joueurs vont vont essayer de de
s'échauffer avec les candidats pas
forcément dévoler toute leur préparation
non plus pour être on a aussi peut-être
un tournoi qu'on a oublié la Global
chess League
2024 attention c'est c'est sponsorisé
par meindra je crois qu'ils ont quelque
chose comme la bagatelle de 3,5 à 5
million d'euros de budget pour ce
tournoi sur une semaine ah mais oui ah
mais c'est c'est ce qui était ce qui
avait lieu à Dubaï l'an dernier oui bah
oui ouioui j'avais oublié bien sûr sera
un autre événement majeur de la saison
ah oui non il révolutionnent tout à
nouveau ils font une commission par
équipe
euh un moment donné avec ouais les
meilleurs joueurs du monde les meilleur
joueus des juniors ouais c'est bon c'est
un peu un all St game oui c'est vrai que
c'est fantastique j'avais eu la chance
d'ailleurs de de commenter la grande
finale avec Eurosport donc bien sûr si
Eurosport diffuse c'est alors ça c'est
quelle date tu peux tu peux nous donner
aussi cette date qu'on est comment il
s'appelleel la global espant que ça ne
chevauche pas une nouvelle
fois la game sonne quoi global chess
League c'était les triven continental
Kings qui a remporté le Global chess
League l'an dernier voilà des équipes
identifiaable alors nom donc en 2024
est-ce qu'on a déjà les dates ça doit
déjà se trouver he c'est une compétition
qui est qui est là pour s'installer hein
dans le dans le CAL avec des
franchises extraordinaire euh alors
attends j'ai mal tapé faudra que
j'éccrive 2024 peut-être demander pour
faire une franchise mais c'est c'était
qui coûte plusieurs millions c'est vrai
que c'est quand même une
compétion majeur et ben bizarrement
écoute je ne trouve pas la date
facilement alors il y aura à mon avis
hein je sais qu'il y aura en fait je
sais que c'est déjà prévu pour 3 années
oui oui oui bah c'est quand même normal
tel succès de pas se contenter d'une
seule
année été suivi par des millions de
spectateurs
ils n'ont pas de de site internet encore
et il y aura aussi et il y aura aussi
Fabien ne pas oublier fin août le
championnat d'Europe par équipe qui
avait eu lieu à deldorp cette année avec
les équipes quand tu fais tes équipes un
peu comme tu veux c'est que d'Europe
c'est pas du
monde tu équipes qui se forment comme
elles ont envie c'est que juste tu fais
une liste avec des potes tu as le droit
de de participer et ça ce sera en
août on saura plus vous donner de la
tête von arriver à tout suivre je suis
un peu
inquiet en tout cas une année 2024 qui
qui promet de belles joutes hein et
après en 2025 malheureusement viendra
polluer tous ces tournois et un peu
bloquer le carenderer le match de
championnat du monde probablement ouais
un peu insipide seulement deux
joueurs une partie par jour
maximum Longre en plus est-ce qu' est-ce
qu'il peut gagner AGN cette partie ah je
crois que ça va aller pour Wesley mais
qui n'a pas su profiterent de la
position prometteuse qu' qu'on qu'on lui
promettait à l'issue de l'ouverture
ouais c'est à cause de ce pion E7 là qui
a été donné
qui n'a pas été pris d'ailleurs ouais
renforcer un petit peu le roi noir
maintenant F6 Wesley qui qui
attend petit coup de chat latéral en en
H2 bah ça devrait faire nul
par s de manière de progresser de part
et
d'autrre tu m'as mis en jouie avec ce ce
cal ce programme Fabien parce que à un
moment donné j'ai eu peur je me tiens
est-ce qu'il y aurait pas un peu moins
de tournoi l'an prochain c'est V que
c'est c'est notre
antise CP c'estra que ce rappelant de
toutes les compétitions qui peuvent à
tous ces beaux moments passés à suiv
toutes ces Comps plus palpitantes les
unes que les autres bon peut-être que là
quand même on touche à la
essens attention attention
ouais le renard se fr un chemin Magus le
magicien en
finale ça doit aller mais faire gaffe
ouais étonnant que ce soit mieux pour
les Noirs d'ailleurs je peux comprendre
que pour les joueurs amateurs c'est un
peu bizarre mais c'est c'est juste
concret en fait c'est c'est un peu la
colonne unu l'activité des pièces ouais
qui rent la structure est moins bonne
mais des pièces
là qui moment bien ça coupe le roi
blanc
de est-ce qu'on peut faire tour F2 tour
F3 va la
perdre faire
F5 tant pis tu fais tour5 prend F5 je
file le pion mais je me
cré je un en va
de moi je fer F5 un pion averti en V de
ESS de Me CR pion passer de l'autre côté
làb P que tu vas un peu te
ouis qui suit les
préceptesoi je suis pas si nul en final
parfois quelques bons
réflexes est-ce que sur T 5 tu A4
directement je sais pas
siisre 4
ouais ça me saoule quand même ouais
position pas
facile peut-être je fis B3 C4 quand même
et peut-être il va regretter son cage 2
qui a moins bien mis le roi et c'est un
temps qu' a manqué pourenir ah mais
c'est terrible en plus Magnus il joue
hyper bien là oh [__] ouis c'est hyper
fort c'est hyper bien joué tuas vraiment
pas de coui avec les Blancs et il vient
de l'autre
côté il va faire roi F2 mais ro F2 tour
H3 tour D4 tour
H2 quel enfer
ou tour5 aussi comme tu reprend F5 sur
échec alle là il faut se défendre faut
offrir du ton au
chat hyper bien joué de la part de
Magnus vraiment très très très
joli franchement
chapeau
cou un peu à côté d'après l'ordi qui
vouit faire A4 pour fixer c'est
peut-être plus logique à 4 pour se
donner t une cible en 3
ultérieurement tellement facile à dire
quand on a l'évaluation de
l'ordi les chats doit être en train de
regarder j'ur peut-être m le RO F4 en D4
mais bon pere contresens je sais pas ou
mais tu bloques un peu les pions et tu
protèges un peu h je sais pas pas c'est
dur à dire il a peut-être super bien
joué is là en défense essay de rien
faire maintenant et puis C4 quand il va
se sentir de le
faire tour D2 tour D4 ouais pour
l'instant il compte essayer de faire un
statuco le temps qu'il
peut tour maintenant est-ce que le RO
est pas moins bien placé en D7 non parce
que de toute façon il va faire échec et
tour A6 c'est ça son
truc
tour4
f54 pour
tour4ç faire tour
H2 est-ce qu'on repart avec le ver3
alors plutôt que des4
F4
prise F5 tour C4
F65 ouais bon les de vont F6 F4 3 G5
mais pour avoir ce genre de
chose là c'est bien sa tour elle est
très active à West ça par de
Magnus va prendre
H5
attends attention
attention peutêtre prendre H5 en
fait on va tout bloquer ouais il y a les
de pions qui partent mais alors attends
qu' il av pas le temps de faire ah il a
pas le temps
mais il est en retard non il perd il a
l'air en retard ouis ouais
ouais il est pas content çait
ouais perdu c'est mal passé un moment
mais c'était dur à défendre
Magnus qui fait r qu'on revienne voir où
c'était l'erreur parce que on a cru
qu'il all la tenir il a pas joué
t bien t re d'ailleurs ri sur la colon F
et il y a dame sur échec soit sur la
colon a perdu à ce moment là qu'est-ce
qu' dit l'ordi
alors l'ordi te fait ça ça ça ça bon
admettons il vient d' il f de en fait
ouais mais il a
raison est tellement proche de
dame derrière
maintenant F5 tu es trop et c'est plus
très grave parce
que quo que c'est hyper dur encore
ouais bon c'était hyper dur à défendre
il fallait faire une
sorte
trouour trop dur
donc c'est un problème en fait ce ce
deuxième pion F en fait c'était pas
tenable
humainement bien joué Magnus belle
partie un peu dommage pour Wesley qui
aurait qui éit pas de tenir et qui
devait même ne pas se retrouver en
difficulté mais
euh mais écoute c'est comme ça c'est
toujours difficile c'est final contre
Magnus on le sait pour essayer de choper
ouais qui essaie de défendre plus comme
ça c'était dur de voir le deuxième P F
passé en fait qui est parti c'était joli
ouais ben écoutez Magnus qui vient de 1
et qui va avoir une balle de
7 avec les Blancs faudra ne pas perdre
peut-être une Pirque comme Wesley nous
en a joué jusque jusqu'alors on va voir
on vous dit à à très
[Musique]
bientôt is a performance enhancer you
don't see it how about now manage your
air quality sharpen your performance
change the game with air things a new
opening for your wall is capture new
major pieces on unique metal from displ
now with theicial collection from
Chess.com Mount them in seconds with fre
magnet K and swap them whenever you like
make your an exclusive discount on all
metal proc shop now with the codes
[Musique]
displ.com
c'est reparti peut-être pour la dernière
partie qui n'a pas jouer la pire comme
il l'ait joué à deux reprises dans must
twin qui joue la Sicilian et Magnus qui
joue la très solide variante àapine très
dur de s'imposer avec les noir contre
cette manière d'affronter la Sicilienne
le répertoire facile rappelonsle
et c'est une partie qu'il est obligé de
gagner hein avec les no il doit gagner à
la demande avec les pièces noires en
plus vraiment il est devant un challenge
colossal on va voir s'il y
arrive VI de jouer le coup D6 alors bien
sûr les blancs peuvent prendre le cent
dans J D4 pe aussi jouer peut-être un
coup C4 choisi D4 logique c'est prend
réuss échanger vite beaucoup de pion
c'est pas mal ça simplifie ça dégage la
position on peut respirer un peu
mieux dame prend qui doit pas être une
une mauvaise idée je
pense on prend aussi bien sûr est-ce que
tu penses qu'il va réussir à faire nul
sur demande Magnus avec les pièces
blanches ah normalement il est assez bon
pour ça mais effectivement c'est sa
mission faire nul sur
de
ça me prend des
qu est-ce que tu penses qu'on va Esser
un peu désabuser oui il est un peu
désabusé là on sent son désabus
d'ailleurs il est encore une fois gêné
par ces cette
lumière est-ce que tu penses que les
chats sont ah benah les chats ont faim
les chats ont faim
et se dis encore de la croquette sèche
quoi ou ça
mole ils sont pas non ils sont pas ravis
les chats c'est
sûr un petit espoir peutêre deégaliser
et avoir encore lesespoir de un
Armagedon et peutêtre remporter C
Armagedon pour mener une manche à zéro
mais bon rassurez-vous les chats demain
il y a quand même une deuxième manche
quand bien
mêmeley perdre aujourd'hui encoreoir on
ne le souhaite pas mais oui demain quand
même on espère on
espère l'emporter pour pouvoir manger du
thon très goûtu
boîte de thon est-ce que tu penses que
c'est du thon pour chat ou c'est du
thon alors je sais pas d'ailleurs ce
qui des petits navires en concert ou du
thon un peu à l'huile àespagnol déjà
supérieur moi je le un ton rouge
entier régalezvous les chats on l' bien
mérité
réfléchit il est en travers de des chats
travers de la route des
chats n'a-t-il pas peur de rentrer ce
soir dans sa chambre
d'hôtel ch pourrait venir les
laacérer coup de griffe
quoi Magnus qui se développe d'après
l'ordinateur les noirs qui ont déjà pris
l'avantage c'est c'est la force de ces
avec les
Noirs l'adversaire à faire un nul sur
dememande jamais facile jamais facile
noir prennent so l'avantage après
quelques coups simplement d' l'intérêt
peut-être de jouer ton répertoire normal
oui pour être mieux au lieu d'être moins
bien avec en faisant peur avec les ves
de nul des fois HM
bon enfin il pas non plus très mal avec
les blancs tout va tout tout va plutôt
pas trop mal mais c'est que j'aurais
plus vu mettre le fou vers D3 E4 viser
le rock oness un coup comme k C6 para
logique pour les noir développant le
cavalier attaquant la dame mettant une
pression sur le
centre est-ce qu'il va pouvoir gagner
avec les noirs sur
demande en tout cas un des deux joueurs
va arriver à accomplir cette mission
sur demande
exactement c'est tout ce qu'on leur
souhaite alors l'humidité quand même
fait plaisir quand même un petit peu
remonté par rapport à hier ça reste pas
terrible c'est
24,2 mais qu mieux que les 15 16 17 17
18 % peêtre qu'on avait hier désertique
très sec là bon quand même la qualité de
l'air est plutôt bonne on voit qu'on est
dans le vert donc qu'on est rassuré
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour laquelle on a C une belle
finale voi les très joli siège secret
Lab sur lesquels les joueurs sont
assis qui n mettent extrêmement
bien tout le confort qu'il faut le dos
bien
calé une époque sur des chaises des J il
a des qui on des problèmes de dos comme
kramnick qui en a fait un peu toute sa
carrière alors que peut-être il a de tel
sièg plus confortable il aurait pu
bienass comm il
faut mais bon ça c'est il a l'air dépité
ou c'est c'est l'évolution technologique
du du
matériel qui permet aussi ses
avancées ça essayer de jouer en tout
cas
il a l'air dépité
ouais çaéresse pas trop
dir l'ordinateur est même plutôt content
de son début il prend5 fait F D6 bon sur
les
pièces après évidemment c'est a une
longue route pour essayer d'aller
de s'imposer mais quoi qu'il en soit il
va pouvoir jouer une partie et puis on
verra il a plutôt fait
fou7 un petit coup de développement
préparant le petit
rock
quoi faire petit rock
iciou c'est le coup qui semble
effectivement logique je jouerai à
priori sans sans grande hésitation côté
blanc mais bon il peut peut
peut-être une journée qui pourrait finir
très tôt il n'est que
20h26 vendredi his soire qui pourrait
être bien terne
Fabien pour se retrouver à devoir aller
au restaurant ou aller boire des vers
pour pour ne pas
s'ennuyer c'est fini après cette game et
oui malheureusement malheureusement si
Magnus ne perd pas il faut vraiment une
victoire de de Wesley de manière
obligatoire mais si Wesley
vient à ne pas
l'emporter sera la fin des échecs pour
ce
soirus pas d'ArmA
Guedon
sera un petit peu décevant
mais tellement eu de spectacle depuis le
début de la composition avec tous ces
arm donc
que on peut pas non plus on réclamait
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours il y en a eu tous les jours
jusqu'à présent quand même c'est pour ça
on disit tiens
peut-être
il y a pas eu un moment un moment du
temps où il aurait pu avoir un armagadon
il y a toujours eu
armagadon il n' pas eu encore le moindre
armagenon
loupé dans
délectre une question il y a un coup de
ça vu qu'on a un petit dégag avec le
chat hein on peut pas répondre en direct
en direct je crois que quelqu'un se
questionnait que se passe-t-il sur fou
prend D5 qui semblait gagner un pion
alors le problème pour les blancs c'est
qu'à la fin les vont prendre ici et
récupérer le
pion parce que tuimmois bien prendre
mais la dame est en prise et si tu
échanges tu n'attaques plus et donc les
Noirs aur un pion central la paire de
fou et serait mieux avec une tour plus
déjà bien placé sur la colonne donc non
mauvaise idée mais il fallait voir tout
ça ça n'échappe pas l'il de LyX d'un
Magnus Carlsen qui n'a pas mordu à la et
qui achanger simplement D6 et jouer
tour sa tour en
jeu il sont très égal
les PD2 ça se
développe il faudra arriver à développer
ce fou C8 pour Wesley ou arriver à jouer
un coup comme E5 à un moment pour pour
sortir le
fou il est loin de gagner ah il y a du
travail a du travail c'est
c'est solide un côté blanche pas choisi
par hasard par le
norvégien qui a l'air d'avoir le seum
alors que quand
même même s'il est loin de gagner il a
pas pas la pire position possible après
l'ouverture non non tout à fait ou c'est
franchement ça peut jouer
enfin un moment que le meilleur gagne
j'ai envie de dire mais c'est pas une
position où tu te faisement sécher donne
une bel avantage
noir mais je comprend pas ce qu'il
arrive au joues pourquoi ils arrivent
plus à faire nul avec les
Blancs g dans ce c'est pas qu'il
arrivent pas c'est que tu l'impression
qu'il y a nettement plus de victoires
euh noir qu'autre chose c'est une
explication possible Fab ou pas du
tout peut-être ilils ont tellement envie
de jouer un
Armagedon mais c'est un peu étonnant non
oui c'est vrai qu'on a pas trop l'tud de
voir les joueurs avec les Blancs perdre
quand ils peuvent juste pas prendre de
risque et échanger mais surtout qu'ils
sont systématiquement enfin quand bien
même ils font nuls ils sont quand même
sous pression ils sont systématiquement
mal en fait parce que là c'est vrai que
c'est étonnant de la part de Magnus
d'avir laissé ce coup de cavalier vers
F4 avec tempo
gratuitement l'adversaire peut aller
peut-être vers D3 puis ou après F B
taper vers G2 peutêtre on reprend espoir
qu pouron on va voir c'est pas fait mais
déjà un peu plus de chance qu'il a un
coup clairement clairement
Fabien Chan se
délecter
augmente mais je suis étonné d'avoir
autant de mauvaise
parties j très bien dans le match rien
acheter
bon
et
là première petite glissade attention il
pas encore perdu du
tout mais peut se mettre un peu en
difficulté noirs qui sont un pe plus
entreprenant dans la
position
9 28 contre 8
mais ouais mais c'est bizar en fait à
chaque fois il te jouent pas leur
répertoire
principal c'est c'est une constante et à
chaque fois ils sont mis
mal pas forcément jusqu'à perdre
mais il y a beaucoup de défaites et quoi
qu'il en
soit j'arrive pas trop à mexpliquer non
parfois des tournois où ils sont hyper
cliniqu et ils font que des nuls hyper
facilement
bizarre en tout
cas c'est pas pour nous déplaire Fab ni
à nous ni au chat qui peut-être se
remett à rêver de de PO
son donc ça voilà qui compte mettre son
fou en B7 et mettre une belle pression
vers le le rock
adverse peut-être des sacrifices à un
moment des pièces qui vont arriver c'est
c'est jamais très plaisant pour les
blancs de de faire face à à tout cux qui
B3 jouer par Magnus donc fou B7 doit
être un coup coup complètement descend
ici je pense c'est le coup qui va jouer
fou B7
hein peut-être F a 6 pour all leschanger
ce que je pense
aussi c'est quand même favori pour faire
nul encore avec les Blancs attention
hein peut-être ah si çave les prévention
de laavée du four comme ça tu mettas
fond B7 qui resterait là-bas sans
être4 tu t'en
fousch
ouais match car tu super cool au niveau
de jeu ouais c'est vrai que celui qui
avait eu lieu là il y a 3 mois la finale
c'était vraiment cool mais c'était plus
intense en fait il y av beaucoup moins
de pause du coup tu sors moins du match
moi je je trouve un peu que c'est pause
là rallonge ça ça sort les joueurs LEF
ça fait trop baisser
l'intensité je sais pas entre ces
parties combien mais les parties d'avant
je crois qu'il y a eu 20 ou 25 minutes
de pause entre les parties quand
même après voilà c'est la
question le bon dosage pour quand même
laisser au jur le temps de de souffler
de se reposer de reprendre leur esprit
et de pouvoir nous jouer vraiment leur
meilleurs échecs
et plus du spectacle évidemment Mme bien
enchaîner aussi bien de faire 3 5
minutes entre les deux premières 10
minutes entre les deux après de nouveau
tu faire blanc noir vraiment avec toi
alle on va dire 3 minutes tu segmentes
en de après tu fais 10 minutes quand
même que tuas le temps d'aller un peu
vcup machin et tu refais 3 minutes
quoi j' donner un genre de bouton au
joueurs le droit de demander 5 minutes
au cas où un buzer un buzer où tu veux
le faire une
fois joue fou F6 un coup qu'on avait pas
mais peut-être qui compte
jouer pour 5 un jour ou à 6 B5 B4 avec
le fou sur cette diagonale
là pourquoi
pas un petit avantage à long terme on va
voir s réussi à le
transformer ce qui serait bien quand
même pour serait de jouer un peu plus
vite quand même
V mettre une pression à la pendue aussi
ouais que murtapp élargir la zone du
combat
tu peut-être faire 3 minutes de pause et
7 que une fois tu as le droit de un
genre de
buzzeras tétendre de de rallonger la
pause une
fois par match j le Ve un peu comme à
l'époque dans les match champion du
monde quand tu P récamer le genre de
repos tu le
voulais ça sera 5 minutes de repos
parce qu'au final tu vois les parties
sont assez courte et même si ça
s'arrêtait là tu on serait presque à 3h
de
match qu' y a une partie qui était pas
qui est peut-êt pas très longue même si
parti dur un peu moins de 3h de match
ou moyenne 4 ouais
ouais tu as bien eu entre les les trois
parties quasiment 50 minutes de pause à
mon avis oui oui pas loin d'une heure de
pause et 2 2 et 3 et 3 et 4 tuas pas
loin d'une heure de pause
bon ch s son que les échecs c'est un jeu
qui s'enchaîne je sais pas comment
dire
un jeu de flow quoi hm hm
oui non non faut pas
s'endormir une petite pause mais pas
trop longue ça enchaîne tout le temps
tout le temps c'est c'est lourd
mais 5 minutes ça va
quoi
je pense qu'il hésite à F F4 en
fait il a pas très envie de le faire
parce que tu CDES avantage à long terme
avec la paire de fou mais en même temps
ça tuas pas mieux ça te permet de régler
ton problème de développement quoi une
bonne fois pour toutes et peut-être
d'avoir le temps d'envoyer un FO à
6 avantage à long terme oui non parce
que si tu réussis
à capturer le fou
adverse cavalier fou contre paire de
cavalier c'est peut-être pas si grave au
final non mais bon petit
plus mais c'est pas grave non
non rien est grave
hein après F tu veux vraiment garder ton
fou tu fais fou D7 hein c'était pas là
où tu étais censé aller mais
mais fou F4 tour D1 qu
si met dans VO en
[Musique]
D7 te faire fou B5 et D4 on va réussir
quand même juste en force à t'échanger
tes
trucs réfléchi longtemps sur ce coup
Magnus il réfléchit même très longtemps
et il fait
fou3 il a pas vou il a pas voulu le
donner céder son fou comme
ça des VE fou
5 ve lui prendre l'autre avec B5
maintenant le petit à tout fou à 6
maintenant
donc le foot cas blanche de westle va
rester vivant pour un petit moment
encore pour venir en B7 sans craind les
échanges après FO 6 et peut-être donc
PIR faire B5 et prendre le foot case
blanche en tout cas Wesley qui jouer à 4
non fait des
choses je pense qu'il va jouer à
je pense qu' va la perdre Magnus en
fait je sens mal pas à l'aise là il se
met un peu trop en PLS par rapport à ce
que
c'est de pas être très satisfait de lui
de retrouver se retrouver un petit peu
sous pression avec les Blancs c'est
c'est jamais plaisant surtout que là
quand même la victoire en 7 lui tend les
bras
et bon tu vois des scénarios
pas si
facile F B de
jouer il pourra pas reprendre de la tour
mais du cavalier je
dirais il pe pas prendre la dame non
plus qui do défendre en F4 le F F6 bon
pas mal placé CE6 qui serait dévoué à à
reprendre et pour du FPR F3 peut-être du
cavalier H3 peut-être des fois des B5 et
cetera pas mal
d'idées il faut jouer la
Magnus alleer chercher le demi-point Fab
en D8 il a pris du Fou pas du cavalier
contrairement à ce que je
croyit est-ce qu'il y a un problème sur
qui 8 que c'était pas le coup de l'ordi
non plus et c'est quand même plus
logique non il y a pas de
problème c'est hyper logique
hein c'est la logique même voilà il joue
sur sa colonne bon pour replacer son F
F6 il l'aimit bien et il serait bien
placé il maintient une petite pression
dans la position sans créer de grandes
menaces mais peut-être B5 gagner la
paire de fou un joueur B4 attaquer la
chaîne de pion et
cetera ça paraît
logique il y a 2 minutes d'avance faudra
essayer de les conserver
Wesley cette pression à la nul parce que
je suis pas sûr qu'il y a de grand chose
à calculer ici de
de d'extraordinaire al peut-être il
essaie de faire marcher des coups comme
k pr G2 mais peut quand même bien blindé
malgré les clouages qui vont arriver
mais on pe ramener le fond2 un cavon D2
il se retir du clouage ensite et ça va
pas être assez donc faut regarde cavaler
E5 prend5 fou prend G2 mais eu 5 qui a
fou F prend
f43 non mais pr pr f F4
peut-être prend f1ou prend F1
oui mais je ça ça peut se regarder
h regarder du coup un comme G5 aussi un
peu bizarre mais quand tu V vraiment
jouer le gain G5 c'est pas complètement
débile mais bon après je veux dire tu
peux rien avoir contre faire F F6 vite
et avec pression à la pendule
et pr pour la pendule s'envole un petit
peu attention
westle on a vu dans d'autres situations
notamment la partie de Maxim contre
Nakamura quand tu veux mettre trop
pression et jouer trop vite des fois ça
se retourne aussi contre toi donc c'est
jamais il fait fou
E7 Magnus plus que de
2 minutes
simplement mais c'est pas simple à jouer
pour les blancs il y a pas de coup
simple facile évident de plomb clair il
y a une petite pression latente dans
cette position il a échangé ça y est
dame prend dame E2 il se replace cette
dame qui était ENF en F1 un peu un peu
hor jeu
qui je pense fallaitchanger des pièces
ça enlève des idées hein sur ce pion G2
quand
même j'aurais quand même préféré voir le
FO F6 tu aurais quand même donné des
idées de cavalier E7 pour rebondir
plutôt que là il vouit un peu Pau et
peut-être qu'il voulait pas voir qu'
arriv en C5 donc céit peut-être ça son
idée aussi puis fut un F6 quelque part
il taper sur le muret donc qu'on peut
attaquer au Polet quoi le Polet B4 allez
G3 ça peut aller peut-être le fou qui va
venir4
Fab ça si réussi à mettre un fou4 un
cavalier en D4 il pourra échanger un peu
les
pièces
C7 tant pis peut-être faire F5 prendre
le risque d'AB la
structure G4 donc pas de 4
prend dame 4 non plus pour les mêmes
raisons
minut 30 d'avance ça peut compter c'est
pas facile à jouer là pour le coup
non comme
cavalierquel je pensais
effectivement c'est
triste au pire on échangera les dames la
tour 5 et on place nos pièces on espère
le mieux pour la
finale Magnus là qui se retrouve mal a
temp ça sent l'armagedon Fab quelle
superbe nouvelle ah ça serait beau j'y
croyais pas trop jeux dire avant la
partie et bon peut-être peut-être
peut-être qui est peut-être en train de
gagner sur
demande pressionnant de sa
part 2 minutes d'avance la position est
pas gagnante mais un avantage certain ce
dessine pour le joueur
américain faut probablement les échanger
ces dames on n pas beaucoup beaucoup de
choix il réfléchit encore
Wesley
bientôt passer sous la barre de 2
minutes à son
tour les conditions de jeu qui sont
durci plus de CO2 dans
l'air c'est normal c'est la tension plus
qu'une minute d'écart
Fab Magnus qui psychologiquement fait
peur à tout le
pas envie de RER mais parfois c'est
quand tu lâch Mo
coups vite 3 secondes la
p
encha un petit peu 40 secondes
d'avance c'est la limite c'est mieux
pour les noir mais je pense qu'on encore
plus proche de nul que de
victoire est vraiment entre là entre les
deux
mais Magnus là vient de faire mal
psychologiquement avec sa série coup
parce qu'il a cert tqué beaucoup de
temps mais il a réussi à repousser
l'initiative adverse il échange des
cavaliers est-ce qu'on ramène un peu le
roi en
jeu ro f1ite sûrement pour fou
F3 pass tour en l'air en D1 c'est 5
jouer peut-être veut isoler le pion
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée non ça
suff pas pas suffisant je pense va
reprendre avec la tour ouais non au
final de fou ce serait pas
suffisant je pense ro F1 ro e1in oui à
mon avis il va monter son Rossier avec
les noir peut-être mettre le fond B6
couir atttion il a pas ro F8 qui prend
E6 hein ça
rode B6 d'abord alors fa B6 RO1 il ro F8
F
F3 tu veux échanger comme ça peut-être F
prend des4 quand même F prend B7 fprend
F2 RO2
devrait changer les
tours
B4
plan la lig principale de l' mais le
plan un peu
humain
part
facilement je
pense pour aller changer les pions de
l'autre côté le RO1 super bien placé il
a super bien joué la
Magnus final il est il les joue bien
même en
défense F5 faut cliquer faut jouer vite
de toute façon fou C6 jouer
admettons fa F3 logique faut F3 on a
fait tout ça pour ça au
final et maintenant peut-être B4
F des 5 bien joué aussi il faut se
déclouer fauter les pion monter
droit
F c'est pr de l'ordi
encore il veut du Fou B7 maintenant
peut-être un jour
C4 en
vérité fou en D4 peut-être de
contourner c'est une erreur C
j'ai les même réflex que Magnus c'est
pas les meilleurs coups
mais j'ai regardé beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de ces
parties
fort fa à 5 il y a pas c 5 à 3 juste
si c'est la gaffe c'est 5 à3 cétait
l'idée de Magnus id de
C4b bon
peut-être4 c'est n
bien c'est pas
graveos ça sera un peu même la finaleon
vu tout à l'heure il faut
[Musique]
faireig blan vont plus bougerire G4 F3
tout
ça
qui va
tenir essayer un petit peu mais on a
déjà vu exactement cette finale tout à
l'heure
et c'est exactement la
même et voilà Magnus qui fait nul sur
demande peut plus bouger pe plus avancer
avec les noirs
dommage Westley qui a eu sa chance mais
vraiment dur à battre ce Magnus et donc
qui remporte le le premier set de ce
match
euh on va vous laisser là on se retrouve
demain on vous envoie un petit raid vers
la chaîne de Chess.com anglais quoi et
on se retrouve demain on vous laisse
tout de suite comme ça vous avez le
temps de voir les interviews J et vous
délecter et on se retrouve demain pour
la suite et fin de cette finale